what's going on reject nation Greg Elba
yeah John we are going to watch today
Deadpool to the final trailer before we
go into this I wanted to give a patron
of the day shout out to Eric Oliver last
night we did at Google hangout with this
handsome young gentleman 29% Great
Britain the rest is African according to
his genealogy test he took he is also
named Eric Oliver Eric meaning eternal
ruler his middle name is king so you
know this guy's one cocky son of a B and
you know what man your confidence has
inspired me you are not a shy guy as
much as like to claim because you my
friend are a leader John give him a
compliment I think you're an incredibly
crisp dude I'm taking notes from you
every chance that I get you have a
pleasant disposition you seem like a
friendly cat got a good taste man and
I'm glad that we got a chance to say
hello if that's what I ever say about
the matter about the situation with you
too long John we're getting close it's
my first step
intercept the convoy breaks a nose
studio that killed a super duper [ __ ]
group it's time to get back on LinkedIn
let's meet in the middle and say no
[Laughter]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the last reaction we did it would be a
very similar review as to what we did
last time but there were some killer
jokes I like what they're doing with
cable that they're setting him up like
he's a bad guy probably in the first
half but you know he's not gonna be a
bad guy by the time this movie ends
especially in the comic book series
there's even like a cable and Deadpool
comic book series where they're teamed
up and then the action does see more
amps the team does look cool I just
gotta say man like some of these jokes
in here so dark the joke that really was
just killing me oh that's move-in x-men
origins Wolverine when bullets are
flying at him he is doing this thing
[Music]
this trailer to me just led with jokes
and action like that yeah that's the
main flavor I got was there's gonna be
tons more action tons more humor and a
lot of people flying in midair from
different scenarios both skydiving
related and just like flipping us as
cars and [ __ ] flow yeah yeah the humor
in this the action in this the ensemble
just the way they're kind of focusing on
like this wacky team that they're
building up together like this made me
actually really excited to have Deadpool
back again further and I like shying
away from TJ Miller at all in this
trailer is kind of interesting
especially with all the serious crap
that he's kind of been going through
some weird situations but I feel like
that's kind of the life of being TJ
Miller yeah weird well he's phoning in a
phony bomb threat though it's a really
serious thing but yeah apparently it's
TJ Miller and he can just get away with
anything can't he well he made a public
prison
the public doesn't seem to get mad at
him I mean the government will get mad
at him Authority will get mad at him but
we won't care at a Deadpool trailer he's
still funny to us this is a great
trailer man I'm so excited for this
movie can't wait to get my tickets
alright guys well you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our vids is up and you can
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly q and A's would
love to have you become a patron
objected I yes ma'am